هذا هو أول هاتف أطلقناه على
الموالية ، وهذا يعني بالنسبة لنا
أن الجهاز الذي يمكن للمحترفين الاعتماد عليه
لإنجاز عملهم باستخدام هذه الكاميرات الثلاث
لديك تحكم إبداعي مذهل ، على
سبيل المثال ، يمكنك استخدام
المقربة والاقتراب  هدفك
لتكبيره حقًا أو يمكنك استخدام العرض
العريض لإخبار المزيد عن قصة أو
يمكنك الخروج بالكامل إلى العرض
العريض للغاية والكشف عن المحيط الكامل
الذي يمكنك التقاط جميع
اللقطات الثلاث من نقطة مراقبة واحدة الآن  دعنا
نتحدث عن الفيديو ، iPhone 11 Pro هو
نظام كاميرا فيديو جديد قوي ، جميع
الكاميرات الثلاث تلتقط إطارًا بدقة 4k 60 ،
وفيديو ثاني النطاق الديناميكي الممتد مع
إبرازات جميلة وتفاصيل الظل
التي لم يتم تصويرها فحسب ، بل تم تحريرها
بالكامل أيضًا على iPhone 11 Pro.
أشياء ذكية مثل أننا في الوقت الفعلي
نأخذ البيانات من الكاميرا التي
تلتقطها وتقوم بتجهيز
الكاميرات الأخرى تلقائيًا للتركيز
التلقائي ودرجة حرارة اللون والتعرض التلقائي حتى تعيين درجات الألوان
حتى تتمكن من الحصول على صورة سلسة
الانتقال عبر جميع الكاميرات الثلاث
بينما نقوم بتقليل أي تغيرات في اللون أو
التعرض ، فإنه يأتي بحجمين خمسة
فاصل ثماني بوصات وست فاصلات وخمس
بوصات لديهم أعلى
كثافة بكسل في أي شاشة عرض Apple تجعل
شاشة Super Retina الخاصة بنا هي الأكثر
تقدمًا لدينا  من أي وقت مضى مدمج في iPhone ،
لذا سيبدأ iPhone 11 pro بسعر 9.99 دولارًا ، بينما يبدأ سعر
iPhone 11 pro بحد أقصى 100 دولار فقط عند
عشرة وتسعين وتسعين